For media-rich applications,
bitmaps are everywhere.
But these high
resolution images can
cause a horde of
performance problems
if the size of the image in
memory is larger than the size
you're displaying it on screen.
My name is Colt McAnlis and one
of the most important things
you can do to alleviate
memory pressure in your apps
is resizing your bitmaps.
This is actually a
pretty common problem.
Let's say a developer
has a photo gallery
app where you can scroll
through pictures and drawings
that the user has
made on their device.
Now, most of these images
are super-high resolution.
But in gallery mode,
you're only displaying them
as small icons,
which means you've
got a huge image in memory.
But on the screen, it's
only 1/10 of the size.
The issue here has
everything to do
with taking up blocks of memory
that you're not actually using.
Those large images occupy big
spaces in your memory heap,
leaving less space for the
rest of your application.
However, resizing
those images to match
what they look
like on the screen
reduces this unneeded
memory bloat,
which, of course, puts
less performance pressure
on the rest of your system.
What you really
want to do here is
find a way to load
the image into memory
at the dimensions
it'll be displayed at
rather than at full resolution.
Later, when the user wants to
see the full resolution image,
you can display it and load
it into memory on demand.
Scaling your bitmaps is such an
important operation on Android
that the platform provides a
whole group of ways to do it.
So you don't have to write
any of that code yourself.
First up is the
createScaledBitmap function.
This API will take
in an existing bitmap
and create a new bitmap
with the exact dimensions
that you've selected.
On the plus side,
you can get exactly
the image size
you're looking for,
regardless of how it looks.
But the downside
is that this API
requires an existing
bitmap in order to work,
meaning that the image
would have to be loaded,
decoded, and a bitmap created
before being able to create
a new, smaller version.
This kind of a dealbreaker
for most app developers
who tend to be memory conscious.
Instead, they
prefer to find a way
to do the resizing
of their bitmaps
at load time, which is something
that the inSampleSize flag
of your bitmap's Option
object can do for you.
Having this property
set to a non-1 value
will result in an
image that's a fraction
of the size of the original
without having to load
in the full sized image.
For example, setting
inSampleSize to 2
returns an image
that's half the size.
And setting it to 4 returns
an image that's 1/4 the size.
Basically, image sizes will
always be some power of 2
smaller than your source size.
Now, inSampleSize is a
really fast operation.
Effectively, it will only
read in every few pixels
based on its value.
So an inSampleSize
of 1 means it'll only
read in every other pixel.
But if you want to scale your
image to a dimension that's
not equal to a power
of 2, then you'll
need the inScaled, inDensity,
and inTargetDensity flags
of BitmapOptions.
See, when the inScaled
flag has been set,
the system will derive
the scaling value
to apply to your bitmap
by dividing the target
density by the current density.
Using this method
will resize your image
and also apply a resizing
filter to it-- that is,
the end result will look better
because some additional math
has been taken into account
during the resizing step.
But be warned, that extra filter
step takes extra processing
time, which can quickly
add up for big images,
resulting in slow
re-sizes, which
is why the super
magic trick here is
to combine these two options.
inSampleSize will first
be applied to the image,
getting it to the next power of
2 larger than your target size.
Then inDensity and
inTargetDensity
are used to scale the result
to the exact dimensions
that you want.
Combining these two is
a much faster operation
since the inSampleSize will
reduce the number of pixels
that the resulting
density based step
will need to apply its
resizing filter on.
Now, it's worth pointing out
one particularly tricky problem
here.
How do you get the
source size of the image?
Well, it's a little
bit more difficult
than you'd actually want.
Basically, you have to set
the inJustDecodeBounds value
of your bitmap object, and then
go ahead and decode your image
file.
This will result with the
width and height of the image,
and allow you to go
forward and then do
the actual decode of your
image, finally resizing it
to the size you actually
need, which, by the way,
is a great time to
point out that there
is existing, stable
libraries out there that
handle all of this types of
craziness on your behalf.
In fact, the Glide and
Picasso libraries already
have code to handle this
type of bitmap resizing
as well as a ton of
other functionality
like async decoding and
caching, all of which
makes managing bitmaps
on Android a lot easier.
I mean, it's good to know
the basics of the stuff.
But when it comes to
production level code,
it's usually a good idea
to lean on proven libraries
where you can.
And understanding these
types of trade-offs
is what performance
is all about, which
is why you should check out the
rest of the Android Performance
Patterns content.
And don't forget to join our
Google+ Community to swap
bitmap war stories
with fellow developers.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]